now that the anti-groomer law has been
put into effect in florida we have of
course been warned that apocalyptic
results will follow gay teachers will be
fired and mass gay students will be
expelled gay people walking down the
street will be rounded up and deported
anybody who says the word gay will be
immediately vaporized by a drone from
the sky this is the dystopia that we
were promised and yet nothing like it
has actually occurred in fact um the
media's had to search quite desperately
to find any real-life horror stories
connected to the legislation that they
erroneously labeled the don't say gay
bill
and now they think that they finally
found it the headlines came pouring in
yesterday a teacher in florida has been
fired
for her sexuality they tell us except
there's quite a bit more to the story as
it turns out here's the headline from
the new york post
it says pansexual florida teacher canned
for discussing orientation with students
now according to the article it says a
florida teacher claims she was fired for
discussing her pansexual status with
middle school students whom she then
asked to draw pictures representing
their own sexual orientations cape coral
art instructor casey scott said that her
students were curious about her sexual
orientation and she explained to them
that she was pansexual during a lesson
in march um in march according to nbc2 a
discussion happened in the class and
because of that now i'm fired scott told
the outlet now
uh just to make sure that we give
pansexual casey a fair shake in this
whole thing i want to play some of her
interview with nbc2 where she tells her
sad sad story and uh let's do that now
a discussion happened in class and
because of that
now i'm fired that discussion according
to trafalgar middle school teacher casey
scott centered on student sexuality a
lot of the kids came out to me like oh
well i'm non-binary and a couple kids
said oh well i'm bi
one kid said they're gay she claims
students wondered about her i'm
pansexual
so
like i like
anyone despite
female male
and married to a man she says some
students asked to create art expressing
their sexuality this one's a trans flag
she hung the pictures on her classroom
door they said that it would be in the
best interest if i just got rid of them
now she snapped these pictures showing
how she got rid of them i went over to
the recycling bin i grabbed all of their
flags and all the kids were staring at
me
and i crumbled their flags in front of
them she was sent home and then i got a
call from administration saying that
well at this time we are releasing you
from your contract she showed us social
media posts from students upset over her
firing however the lee county school
district showed us complaints from
parents and students explaining that
they could create flags expressing who
they are union president kevin daley
says they can legally fire her during
that probationary period
they can let you go without cause she
doesn't belong to the union daley
believes the firing could be a wake-up
call for teachers there is kind of a
heightened sense of you know where is
the boundary
yes where is
the boundary
well um i can answer that
the boundary is simply this don't talk
to the kids
about your sexuality or theirs
it's got nothing to do with your job
it's not appropriate
it's none of your business
it's not what you're being paid to do
um i also don't want my kids dentist
talking to them about
their sexuality if the barber cutting my
son's hair is a pansexual and uh brings
that up in in the course of of of
cutting my son's hair i'm gonna have a
problem with that
in fact i don't want any adult talking
to my kids about sexuality so this is
quite simple actually it's
finding the boundary it's not hard to do
and it's really not confusing
it's not difficult to understand or
abide by i've gone
if you can believe this
i've gone my entire life without ever
walking up to somebody else's child and
initiating or participating in a
conversation about sexuality
um i plan to keep that streak alive for
the entire rest of my life it's not
difficult normal people have no problem
with this
the fact that public school teachers are
scratching their heads you know and
going i don't understand it's so
confusing
i'm perplexed
really shows you what's wrong with with
public schools
wait so when can i talk to kids about
sex
never
you never can
it's not your business it's not your job
get that through your thick skulls and
leave the kids alone again nobody else
on earth
it has a problem with this
you people are the only ones who are
confused about it everybody else we live
our entire lives and it's never a
problem
we we intuitively understand that it's
that it is far beyond inappropriate to
have conversations like this with other
people's kids
there is no temptation to have those
conversations there's never
there's no confusion there's no like
searching where's the line where's the
boundary
the boundary could not be more obvious
it's in bright neon flashing colors okay
that's how obvious the boundary is
so let's let's uh take this specific
case into consideration
and it's good because it actually does
demonstrate exactly how the florida bill
will work in action even though this
teacher's firing wasn't really connected
to the florida bill and in fact the bill
only covers kids up to third grade
anyway still
we have a pretty good example of the
kind of thing the bill is trying to
prevent so what happened here according
to pansexual casey who says she's
pansexual because she likes males and
females which actually makes her
bisexual uh the term pansexual is
redundant and meaningless but i mean
never mind that for now
casey says the kids were talking about
their own sexuality and then they asked
about hers
the correct response from a competent
adult in this situation is to say
this topic is not appropriate for the
classroom
and then change the subject
the end
simple
instead casey tells the children all
about the wonders of her made-up
pansexuality identity and invites the
kids to create their own pride flags
which she then hangs up in the classroom
did she deserve to be fired for that yes
without question at best and i mean
the absolute best most generous generous
interpretation here is that this woman
is emotionally stunted immature
ill-equipped and was swept into this
inappropriate classroom conversation
because she lacks the competence and
basic leadership skills to offer the
kind of guidance and set the sort of
example that her job requires um that's
cause enough to fire her but again
that's like the most generous
interpretation
because in reality there's a reason
these kids felt comfortable talking
about this in her classroom in the first
place and even actively you know drawing
her into the discussion it's pretty
clear that she's initiated these types
of discussions in the past she may well
have initiated this one too and is now
lying about it
whatever your theory of the case
there is no plausible theory that
vindicates her
and there's other one other thing i want
to bring up
about this
so let's go back to the clip when uh
pansexual casey says the students wanted
to you know draw the pride flags as an
art project
and apparently they didn't all want that
considering both parents and students
complained after the fact so there were
at least some kids in that classroom who
felt uncomfortable
but many of them did allegedly you know
want to draw the flags until the teacher
was forced to pull them all down crumple
them and throw them away in front of the
class
now it does sound like she made the
whole thing more dramatic and theatrical
than it needed to be like i don't think
she needs to go right in front of the
class and tear down the pride flags that
they just put up and crumple them in
front of them um
it's
kind of funny to me actually but
whether she had to do it that way or not
let's go to
um minute 139 in the clip where we see
all the pride flags crumpled in a heap
now you can see that there now first of
all notice
just how many pride flags there are from
just one middle school art class
i don't know how many kids are in the
class but it couldn't have been more
than 20 or 30 at a maximum probably
fewer than that so
in this one middle school class of a
couple dozen students at most
that's how many identify as lgbt that's
how many pride flags there were and you
heard her say it too well some of them
were non-binary they were trans they
were gay they were bisexual
in a middle school class
and note the actual flags we see there
in the pile
talking about these issues so much i've
unfortunately become very well
acquainted with these flags i'm
something of a pride flag translator now
and i can tell you that
we see there multiple
non-binary flags so these are middle
school kids a group of them in just one
class
who have declared that they're that they
are neither male nor female
and then perhaps even more alarmingly we
see that you can see that purple white
and black flag which is i believe the
asexual flag
so there are middle schoolers young kids
who have decided already that they are
asexual
they've adopted that identity and are
literally waving the flag for it
so if you're wondering why the
anti-groomer laws are needed this is why
the social contagion has turned into a
full-blown pandemic
entire generations are being consumed by
it
children these days are so desperate to
be in the lgbt club that they're
assuming sexual identities that they
don't understand and that don't really
make any sense
[Music]
that's how successful the lgbt
indoctrinators have been
and that's why we have to and are
fighting back
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated